me
c'est un pari assez costaud assez
fascinant même de vouloir raconter une
histoire complètement sans dialogues
cette fois-ci de 80 minutes passent et
on n'est plus dans le carton de sept
minutes c'est autre chose donc on a
rassemblé là tous les meilleurs talents
qui travaillent ou qui ont travaillé
pour nous dans le passé pour essayer de
faire une oeuvre très très accomplie
pour le cinéma de le porter au cinéma
c'était une évidence pour moi
les personnages sont tellement forts
déjà jacques voisin bob à ce nouveau
personnage ou izia les trois cafards
n'en parlons pas son plaisir de pousser
encore plus loin ce qu'on faisait dans
la série une animation plus riche plus
plus plus soigné plus dans les finesses
sont certes ça passe beaucoup par le jeu
c'est évident si le geste est faux aussi
la position là la manière d'être des
personnages est faux ce qu'on comprend
plus rien
le décor c'est comme la musique c'est
pas forcément fait pour être seulement
jolie est pas gêné ça doit soutenir
l'idée d'action
la fonction des dialogues elle est
remplie par autre chose
elle est remplie notamment par toute la
bande son la musique les bruitages qui
sont extraordinairement expressif qui
ont une place évidemment démesurée qui
est très très importante dans un univers
comme hobby on arrive à des choses
extrêmement qu'on va dire affiné seconde
après seconde pour que en permanence
l'attention du public soit là et que les
effets colonna donc la donne soit
énormément d'importance le sound design
les bruitages et la musique ont
énormément d'importance
les bruitages pour accentuer la comédie
la musique pour souligner la narration
qui est très différent raison de deux
rôles différents
gm immo
mission design s'occupe de l'action moi
je m'occupe des émotions
la musique prend en charge travil
intériorité la subjectivité des
personnages leurs émotions
à tel point d'ailleurs que après avoir
regardé le film on n'a pas lu que la
sensation que
personnage se sont pas parlés en fait
puisque datant de choses qui s'échange à
la fois là
le respect de l'univers musical de vie
cette idée d'évolution et ce souffle
épique ces trois choses que j'ai demandé
à vincent et il a fait ça mais avec une
petite flûte s'est fait très vite on
s'est dit que l' usage de l'orchestré
symphonique sera inévitable vu son
potentiel expressif
la musique a une fonction narrative qui
est travaillé vraiment à l'image
on est vraiment au dixième de seconde
à
du coup ce qui se produit à l'écran
m'indique que ce que je dois écrire donc
la partition mais en grande partie de
toute façon des dictées par le film
il fallait trouver une vraie idée qui
justifie le passage au grand écran
il fallait quelque chose qui soit
cinématographique et pas juste les
ingrédients de la télé et demi sur un
grand écran
vous allez retrouver l'univers de guy en
plus grand plus gros plus drôle plus
excessifs